الى ماذا تشير هذه النتائج الاوليه حتى
الان بالنسبه لك بماذا تخبرك
كثيرا
وراينا ان
السيد كمال الكوليسترول وكان متقدما على
اردوغان وربما وجدتنا
استبيانين او ثلاث فقط كان متزنا اذا قمنا
بالتقييم بالنظر الى نتائج تلك
الاستبيانات نستطيع القول ان انها تلك
النتائج كانت خاطئه صحيح الى حد الان قد
تم فتحه
43% من مجموع الاصوات لا نستطيع ان نجزم
ونقول ان هناك فوزا لطرف على حساب طرف اخر
ولكن لو ان احد
المرشحين اردوغان هو كلسترونه ان لم يحصل
على خمسين بالمئه فان الانتخابات ستنتقل
الى الجوله الثانيه وانا برايي ان
اللافت للانتباه
وربما النتيجه المفاجئه هي تتمثل في
الاصوات التي حصل عليها السنان اوغان
ونجد ان كان التوقعات بنسبه الثلاثه فاصل
خمسه بالمئه للسنن اوغان ولكن نجد اليوم
انه قد تجاوز ذلك بكثير وخاصه اذا
انتقلت الانتخابات الى الجوله الثانيه
فان السبب سيكون هو حصول سنان اوغان على
نسبه عاليه من الاصوات غير المتوقعه ايضا
ثم ايضا ان
راينا ان
ما كان يتم الحديث عنها في التواصل
الاجتماعي او من خلال الاستبيانات لم يكن
صحيحا ودقيقا ربما ان صح التعبير ايضا هذه
نقطه ونقطه اخرى انه في المناطق التي
بها
الناخبون الاكراد في شرق وجنوب الشرق
تركيا الان كانت تصويت
لصالح
وهذا الدليل على ان الحزب الكردي الذي
دائما كان يتصدر هذه المناطق انه قد ايد
كريستيانو
وبشكل واضح هذا ما نفهمه من هذا المشهد
الاول ايضا هذا ما يمكن ان اقوله